All the best
Because this is how the base of the Russian invaders needs to
contact the
base of the
Russian invaders in every possible way for
everyday life, including either write like this
or like this in the morning 4
because I think that’s what they
say
[music]
their avionics took them out there to clean the
enemy
And
you see the goal by  on the street Yes, and you pay attention to them
, namely, arrogant, stand like this
that you are here
in your homeland I want to go there, you don’t have to give it
That’s all along the way
I don’t go out at home for three months In the last
month and a half Here I went out
on the street for the first time  yesterday I rode around the city
I just turn our
northern city into the boys with words
like this
[music]
[applause]